and I'm the same an X Factor has been so
impressive
he's been of one-man-army going for the
tanks going for the close range in play
lighting up the other team they are
approaching him from all angles and he
is holding it down I believe this is his
teammate as well no evidence play that
there so I was 249 coming in hot with
that pick good stuff I may do there yeah
definitely I mean look at all the
concentration here all of it going
straight into the game every one of them
intent on getting the getting the points
that they want trying to capture those
objectives you guys may have noticed
that you see couple doors you know
scattered about and here's a good news
there's this really cool eye and a good
revive they're nice just to say that was
gonna be Matt there with that with that
revive so I just want to know one of the
coolest things that that they added in
battlefield one is the charge security
feel good Wesley unprotected no you were
not protected my friend because I can
charge right through that door and say
is I love it you don't have to stop at
the door anymore which is actually a
limitation of some of the older games
where you have to wait and wait for the
pop-up to come up and then you could
open the door again you could of course
blow the door off and then not that's an
option but now you've got literally just
charged straight through it full speed
you don't have to slow down and the
enemy doesn't have that chance to get
away anymore great great shots there a
little bit of a bombing run
it's not bad not bad and again you know
they have so many great players here
from guys who come from the battlefield
community popular content creators and
of course our celebrities that are here
playing today
so you're seeing just the diverse mix of
skill here but what's what's really cool
and always impressive to me is here I
can control a plane to save my life it
is like the saddest thing you someone
watch my stream I remember one time I
hop into a jet and then the jet blew up
the second I got a side of the jet I
don't even know what I did I have no
idea I did it I said I committed you
know I like high IQ myself up Wesley
please well we were looking at a
semi-automatic rifle man you have to
load every single bullet so you know
you've got to be really careful if an
enemy's still hanging around maybe you
don't want to pull over those bullets
and maybe you want to switch to cider
might be a little bit more helpful in
that situation and the sidearms too they
have a lot of kick to them oh yeah you
know in previous battlefields I would be
able to whip out the sidearm and get
some reasonable shots in the distance
this time around though not not the same
thing if that gun has a lot of kick to
it has to a lot of the weapons in this
game you know they have a lot of kick
you know big a lot of different view
bullet drop and drag there's just a lot
of different gameplay mechanics and you
know I played here and also you had
mentioned before are you you lose
requesting point it to be the airship
has arrived yeah it's coming back in
again so we might get a shot of that in
a minute and actually what we should do
is maybe just go into a little bit more
about the the airship and maybe see if
we can show you some of the power that
it possesses could it be good to see
like people firing off some of those
shots showing what damage it does on the
ground be interesting to see here it
comes
and one thing that I think we will
mention about this airship is that it is
fully controllable by the player
now in the past you might have noticed
some of the bigger objects in the
battlefield games
but this one is fully controllable by
the player so all that power you can
take it wherever you like but obviously
it's a huge object in the sky it's not
like you can turn around in a couple of
seconds so if you want to go somewhere
you better pick that out in your head
just as you start using it and then head
for it don't change your mind because it
takes a long time for it to move around
and you could obviously get taken down
by that point and not be as effective
also I want to know - you saw when he
picked up visibility right a lot of
these weapons you know even when you
talk about the airship right like what
it's able to do what it's not able to do
it's still a behemoth right but you know
at that time right visibility was very
limited oh yeah it was all about
protecting yourself so you'd see like
shielding like all over the place yeah
even like some of the armor that you
would see back then because HD wore full
armor in World War one yep it was just
usin see brain weaponry that was that
play at the time but it was like just a
concept of running around with just
full-blown armor and even for those
mounted machine guns you you see the you
know just visibly the black abyss blue
that you have is trade-off for such a
powerful we have correct I mean that's
something that you will know all the way
through battlefield 1 I mean even
looking at it here you can see this
tanks just pushing its way on through
but there are certain areas where you're
like right well I've got to try and get
this tank out of a tiny little gap but
I've got myself stuck in it can't turn
very quickly can't move very quickly so
you really need to be ready for the
situation you've got to learn how things
really work like the semi-automatic
rifles for example once you fight all
those shots you got it individually
reloads where an SMG might be better
because you just pull out a magazine a
pop another one in a way okay so there's
all these different sort of
TripIt little things here that will come
into play and I think that because it's
still the battlefield game that you know
but it's just a little bit different and
it's a little bit I think it feels
better it's it's see the top mounted
magazine they're getting right in the
way like what you were saying it's like
people thought that was the best way to
do things we'll get it top loaded so
it's easier to to fit a new magazine it
oh well it's right in the middle of my
face so no it's just one of those things
we have just an update to the score
there it seems like the German Empire is
doing a really good job continue to rack
up points we have just under like really
like three minutes or four minutes for
this game before it concludes and a
great great run here with the plane does
a substantial amount of damage they're
coming back in for another run and
there's a lot of things that we can
cover about this game you can even see
that here actually when x-factor was
looking at it you can see that the
points wherever there's an explosion
right oh we gonna take it down
that's unfortunate big star just ran
them over so one thing to note when in a
tank
you know explodes right when you shoot a
you know a shell into the ground that
ground now actually changes shape right
if it's fully deforming like you can you
can just lower the ground a little bit
more cover and now I'm starting to see
the rain come into play so it started
off as a beautiful sunny day in st.
Quinton scar and now well I mean like we
were saying this changes visibility and
for people like pilots in the sky even
by
you know you have to drive through grain
now they may have a quite got the
visibility on that other plate that you
were looking to try and take down to
have a change on your tactics try and
take people down on the ground instead
absolutely beautiful I mean look at all
the background imagery as well okay fire
you can see you can really see like the
battle beyond what you're playing is
going on in there as well that's
actually that was a good shot
way to go productions